Okay.
Okay, let's bring this hard.
Thank you.
Okay.
I think when I hit the
jumbie position here,
I tend to, like,
kind of focus a little bit more.
So, like, when my eyes
go from, like, the
floor, like, to the judges
or to the wall, is when
I'm trying to kind of, like, lock in
my mental and
get ready for the plumes.
So, right here,
one of those
technical aspects I've been trying to work on
is my hands coming a little bit
too far to pass
my hips. I was really focusing
on getting them, like, putting them
in the right spot here.
Ooh, my foot
is looking a little bit
incorrect,
but I think
my stance form's alright.
But I was really focusing on
correct stance form, proper
placement of my, uh, my hands.
And then in this part,
I was really
focusing on, um,
my hand coming
to my face
doing a full, complete motion
all the way through, which I think that
I've kind of did correctly here.
And then I tried to do that
with my hands,
but I think that's
where it came into play.
And then, this part
here, um,
one of the most technical things
that I was trying to focus on was,
um,
the movement of my hand.
So, the high-blocking hand
coming across my body
up into my face here.
And then this hand, the
outer-block hand,
coming to the correct, um, height
by my shoulder.
having proper um preparation for my punches so hand out and then and hand out out like that
and then here after that my side kicks trying to make sure it's good form and i'm completing
the kick i stumble a little bit there which is something i noted here i made a mistake there
which i you kind of see in the video i hesitated a little bit and then towards the end here i was
thinking about that mistake and then it kind of made me have a little bit of a bad performance
here at the end and yeah that's the end yeah
it's looking for more information on how you're scored so as you can see
your pattern is scored based on the number 10 so out of